youtube law states that you can't do a
video about 50 shades of grey without
wearing fuzzy pink handcuffs or some
other non-threatening bachelorette party
level signifier of kink that
inadvertently captures the dissonance
between intensity of the marketing
around 50 shades of grey as some really
taboo pushing kink and
the actual product
anyway here's a lukewarm defense of the
first movie
[Music]
the following program deals with issues
of intimate partner violence and abuse
viewer discretion is advised all right
history lesson master of the universe is
a 2009 through 2011 serial twilight fan
fiction written by erica mitchell under
the pen name snow queen's ice dragon and
collected into two volumes in this
alternate universe bella swan is a
university student who falls into the
orbit of vampy but not actually a
vampire billionaire edward cullen after
interviewing him for the school paper
the relationship rapidly and clumsily
escalates with edward stalking bella
kidnapping her revealing his deep dark
secret that he's really into some spanky
stuff then they go back and forth with
bella being alternately scared and
intrigued and repeat for about 700 pages
with a couple stalker subplots and
helicopter crash sprinkled into the back
half and that gets you to the end of
part one where edward asks bella to
marry him the final chapter ending on a
cliffhanger where an unnamed character
swears his revenge on the cullens as he
watches them from across the lake in
part 2 bella and edward get married and
accidentally pregnant edward's sister
alice is kidnapped by bella's former
boss one of the stalkers from the
previous volume bella pays the ransom
and shoots the guy in the leg edward is
like
fine whatever their kid is born the end
i guess
happily ever after they move into a
really really big house but keep the
downtown condo as a dedicated sex den on
a structural level master of the
universe is an alternate universe all
human retelling of twilight so it
doesn't claim to take place in a
contiguous universe with the original
novels and the supernatural elements
have been removed while the story itself
remains largely the same just adapted
for the new gimmick in this case bella
being a university student and edward
being a billionaire who likes to beat
brunette girls that look like his birth
mother
i'm a sadist bella i like to whip little
brown-haired girls like you because you
all look like the crack [ __ ]
my birth mother
still it follows twilight's plot across
the broad strokes bella is pushed into a
scenario where she beats edward they
have some back and forth edward saves
bella from an accident they start a
relationship after edward reveals his
dark secret there's a dinner with
edward's family and the whole thing
culminates in a moment where edward goes
too far with his dark secret as a serial
fan fiction master of the universe was
published first in pieces on
fanfiction.net and starting in early
2010 mitchell began parallel publishing
raunchier versions on her personal site
fiftyshades.com
within the scope of fanfiction.net the
story was a genuine hit attracting an
estimated 16 to 20 000 readers at a very
high level of engagement with people
collectively leaving thousands of
comments and reviews in addition to
talking about it on forums and sharing
it on their blogs this engagement was
further lubricated by mitchell's
aggressive publication speed and her
accessibility chapters were often coming
out every two days for several weeks at
a stretch pushing the story to the front
page of recently updated stories and icy
as she was called within the community
was quick to pick fights with negative
reviews and heap preys on positive ones
this type of spiraling engagement forms
a feedback loop where readers see this
story with thousands of comments amid
stories with dozens and feel compelled
to be in the know to find out what this
thing is that everyone is talking about
the novel fifty shades of grey written
by erica mitchell under the pen name e.l
james was published in may 2011 by the
writers coffee shop an australian
boutique publisher focused on turning
fan fiction into commercial literature
it is a lightly edited version of
roughly the first half of master of the
universe part 1 where the names have
been changed edward cullen is now
christian grey and bella swan is now
anastasia steel when i say lightly
edited i do mean lightly for example
christian now spends 43 dollars at
anna's store rather than the 53 edward
spent at bellas and these ellipses are
now commas yes yes there's more changes
than that if you want to go by absolute
number there's a lot of changes
thousands even once you include
punctuation but it's an understatement
to even say that the core of the two is
the same the two texts side by side read
almost the same with really only a minor
pass for rewording the plot and general
structure remains untouched due to
mitchell's existing passionate fan base
and landing right at the time when
e-readers were really breaking into the
mainstream the e-book of fifty shades
was released to strong initial sales
sending it to the top of the best
sellers list and priming a similar
feedback loop where more and more people
pick it up and start talking about it in
order to be in the know about the thing
that everyone is talking about the
feedback loop was further compounded by
the remainder of master of the universe
being published in september 2011 and
january 2012 as fifty shades darker and
fifty shades freed with both books
seeing similarly strong sales in
addition to engagement both positive and
negative on the social cataloging site
goodreads with multiple erotica books
from the same series on the bestsellers
list media quickly picked up on it as a
curiosity
further boosting its profile by the end
of 2011 the 50 shades books had sold
around 250 000 copies and drawn the
attention of major publishers after a
short bidding war vintage an imprint of
random house now penguin random house
acquired the publication rights in march
2012 releasing the entire trilogy as
mass market paperbacks in april 2012
flooding bookstores around the globe and
cementing 50 shades as a genuine
cultural phenomenon in may 2013
universal and focus features acquired
the film rights for approximately 5
million us and production began on the
big screen adaptation of the trilogy to
be directed by sam taylor johnson
starring dakota johnson as anna and
jamie dornan as christian with the first
film slated for release valentine's day
weekend 2015. now the books are
well
they're pretty bad but i want to cut a
fine line here there's a lot of
criticism that has come at 50 shades
from a lot of different angles some
valid and some distinctly less valid so
for example the pros and the dialogue
are pretty abysmal this is valid
criticism the serial nature of the
original publication is something that
was never worked out in the editing
process so plot threads will abruptly
end the story will get sidetracked and a
random aside for several chapters at a
time that will ultimately be dropped and
forgotten things are rarely foreshadowed
and at least one character that is
integral to the plot link is only
mentioned in passing like
four times in the entire series and
never actually shows up it needs to be
acknowledged as with its origin as an
alternate universe retelling of twilight
and having seen so few alterations
during editing 50 shades falls into some
serious gray areas of plagiarism
beautiful
this is the skin of a killer though i
mean fifty shades has apeked twilight
all the way down to the cover design and
shortly after stephanie meyer scuttled
plans for midnight sun a version of
twilight told from edward's point of
view mitchell announced her plans to
retail 50 shades from christian's point
of view while meyer has refrained from
litigating anything about the
relationship between twilight and 50
shades mitchell's lawyers have not been
so magnanimous and kind cracking down
heavily on derivative works that
capitalize on the popularity of fifty
shades describing them as parasitic this
is itself an extension of mitch's
willingness to pick fights with critics
down to starting petty arguments with
people on twitter the story also via
bella slash anna's running internal
commentary perpetuates dominant cultural
narratives that pressure women to take
responsibility for the abuse that their
intimate partners inflict on them and
much of the interaction between the
leads is more than a little hazy in the
area of consent in a way that many
critics find to be not merely
controversial but disingenuous and even
dangerous
now without getting too deep into the
weeds i want to acknowledge that fantasy
fiction erotic fiction playing with
ideas and scenarios that blur the lines
of consent or even step right over them
aren't strictly illegitimate as subject
matter most of our fiction involves
scenarios that we would never want to
actually experience whether that be
getting caught in a gunfight or trapped
at a cabin in the woods with a killer
and the idea that some people find
non-consensual sexual scenarios
thrilling is maybe not as weird as it's
often painted christine love's visual
novel lady killer in a bind is a text
that delves quite far into scenarios of
dubious consent for the purpose of both
titillating and challenging the audience
it is an experience that can get rough
at times
pun intended playing through one
scenario left me with a lingering sense
of betrayal that took several days to
fully process the game opens however
with a reminder that fiction is a means
for people to explore ideas and
scenarios in ways that are safe or at
least safer in a video game you
effectively have the ultimate safe word
you can exit the program at any time and
it will stop instantly
it's like the fuzzy pink handcuffs
they're not real they're just toys
they look and behave close enough to
reel handcuffs but the key is just for
show it's actually less convenient than
just using the lever in most situations
someone wearing them can pretty
effortlessly get themselves out they are
a form of performative fiction they are
the illusion of danger they are a safer
way to explore the sensation of
restraint of loss of control
but that isn't to say that they are
truly safe
you can still wear them too tight you
can still ignore warning signs and you
can still end up in an awful position
that does lasting damage
similarly fiction provides us a way to
explore ideas and scenarios that would
be hazardous traumatizing or both in
real life
fiction is a way to practice intense
emotional states but that doesn't make
fiction harmless it still impacts us and
indeed impacting us is the entire point
this is why critics argue that the
subject of fictional non-consent can
still be handled more or less ethically
an issue that comes down to framing
something that fifty shades routinely
fails at and fails hard it's not merely
that master of the universe and fifty
shades wander into areas of dubious
consent it's that erica mitchell as a
writer doesn't seem to be entirely aware
that that is the territory that she's in
in a synergy of failings mitchell has
responded aggressively to critics
raising this point including one
delightful incident where she angrily
tweeted at a rape survivor criticizing
the way christian treats anna quote no
rape in fifty shades with the attached
gif hashtag read the book critics within
the bdsm and kink communities have
additionally focused on the book's bad
and unhealthy representation of kink
dynamics and the way that it presents
kink as something that people get into
only because they have serious
unresolved issues with past abuse
these two veins of criticism merge into
the synthesis criticism that fifty
shades of grey does not depict either a
healthy or unhealthy kink lifestyle but
routine domestic abuse being masked as
kink with critics pointing to the many
ways the christian works to undermine
anna's mental well-being her sense of
stability and her ability to consent he
negotiates their sex contract while
applying her with alcohol isolates her
physically and emotionally from friends
and family belittles her interests mocks
her sexual inexperience regularly leaves
her in tears makes her financially
dependent on his approval and constantly
reminds her of both his vast wealth and
his willingness to use it to monitor and
pursue her in a 2012 interview with
books in review mitchell responded to
such criticism with this nothing freaks
me out more than people who say this is
about domestic abuse bringing up my book
in this context trivializes the issues
doing women who actually go through it a
huge disservice it also demonizes loads
of women who enjoy this lifestyle and
ignores the many many women who tell me
they found the book sexually empowering
so it is fair to say that mitchell
herself does not see the parallels
believes that she has crafted a fair if
fantasized version of a kink lifestyle
and has been openly resentful of critics
who insist otherwise
however even with all these criticisms
it needs to be acknowledged that a huge
chunk of the backlash to fifty shades
stemmed from and manifested as rampant
misogyny and an assault on the public
visibility of female sexuality and
sexual agency with many many people
using legitimate criticism as a
springboard to mock mommy porn and the
very idea of women finding anything
erotic if it didn't conform to strict
male-centric ideas of feminine sexuality
in this context it's not even weird to
consider that a certain component of 50
shades success can be attributed to a
collective political act of defiance
women publicly embracing the book not
for its quality or even because it
suited their tastes but because of what
its success represents in a culture that
generally sees pornography for women as
both set up and punchline so before we
start really digging into the meat of 50
shades failings i do want to take a
moment to talk about what resonated with
audiences the books aren't good but it's
disingenuous to insist that no one could
then engage with them authentically it
has clearly struck a chord with its core
audience and developed a loyal fan base
that likes it for what it is in whole or
in part
the first unavoidable connection is as
fan fiction which is where the earliest
fans came on board they weren't reading
an original construct but an explicit
derivative one of the advantages and
indeed one of the foundational appeals
of fan fiction is the ability to
shortcut to the good stuff because so
much about the characters and the world
is able to be presupposed this also as a
side note often leaves fan fiction with
thumb prints all over it as the opening
chapters of an alternate universe story
are going to be largely devoted to
getting the audience caught up on the
deviations from the core that they are
already familiar with this is why 50
shades for example calls explicit
attention to anna getting drunk for the
first time it's an explicit deviation in
bella's character as written in twilight
but there's this appeal to seeing
characters that the audience has already
formed a parasocial bond with in
synthesized scenarios and novel
circumstances this isn't even all that
odd outside the realm of fan fiction dc
comics over the years has imagined
batman as a vampire as a pirate as a
medieval knight and as an 18th century
detective chasing jack the ripper just
to name a few of the literally dozens of
alternate universe batman that are out
there
at a certain point characters cease to
require their context to be whole and in
fact become their own context and
subsequently the fun comes from taking
them and moving them around playing with
them in a variety of different styles
and scenarios in this way fan fiction is
the literary evolution of childhood play
taking disparate toys and bringing them
together an almost instinctive exercise
in creative synthesis it is not a
mystery that fan fiction appeals to so
many because it is naturally what
stories pursue the meeting point between
the familiar and the unexpected moving
beyond the fan fiction many fans enjoy
indulging in the economic fantasy the
thrill of absurd wealth and privilege
the story about an ordinary girl plucked
out of obscurity by an incomprehensibly
rich dude who is able to give her
virtually anything that she wants indeed
elements that many critics have found
odd or infuriating are to the invested
reader part of the appeal anna rejects
christian's gifts which he then imposes
on her this allows the reader to indulge
the dual fantasy of maintaining a sense
of social propriety the self-perception
of being the person who is humble down
to earth and proper while still enjoying
all the material benefits of dating a
man with more money than an individual
could ever spend also we shouldn't leave
it merely implied
many people enjoy the pornography they
find the sexual dynamics and writing
authentically erotic that may seem
unbelievable because the writing is so
often just painful but what do we
benefit critically for pretending that
no one could sincerely enjoy the
material conversely simply because
people enjoy it authentically doesn't
mean that criticism of the material
either in terms of technique or subject
matter become invalid critical readings
of 50 shades that document patterns of
abuse how christian isn't merely
dominant domineering or even just an
[ __ ] but works to tear down anna
coerce her intentionally confound her
ability to consent and isolate her
socially these are still valid and
important readings even if there's an
audience that finds it sexually
stimulating so with all that in mind
what's wrong with 50 shades of grey
well
a lot
a big thing that i want to talk about
because it's going to be the most
relevant later is the legacy of
serialization this is an issue that
compounds as the books go on but it's
significant pretty much right out of the
gate in particular the serial fan
fiction method tends towards a sort of
public performance a writer might
publish a short dead-end chapter purely
because they haven't posted anything in
a few weeks and their fans are wondering
if the fick is dead ideas might catch
the author's attention but after a few
weeks they decide it just isn't going
the direction they or the audience want
and so the plot thread is abandoned
because the nature of serial fiction is
to always keep pushing forward and edits
are only made chapter by chapter these
problems then persist into further
derivatives for fifty shades of grey and
specific these mostly manifest as a lot
of cyclical repeating scenes in the
middle of the book petty arguments and
conflicts that happen often enough that
it's hard to remember which specific one
was in which specific chapter and
numerous side stories that last a
chapter or two before abruptly ending
now ideally these are exactly the kind
of issues that an editor would address
in adapting a fan fiction from forum
thread to published novel and
this is as good a time as any to mention
that erica mitchell is by all accounts
absolutely awful to work with reportedly
the first editor she was assigned at the
writer's coffee shop tasked with turning
master of the universe into fifty shades
was removed from the project after
mitchell complained that she was trying
to make too many changes to the
structure of the books that kind of
behavior is going to come up again when
we're talking about the movies and she's
spending an hour on set screaming at the
director over changes to dialogue
speaking of the dialogue it's uh
it's not good
i'm going to lump anna's internal
monologue in with this because the words
characters say aloud and the things anna
thinks to herself
tend to play off each other in
the worst way
i could always take them off he smirks
um
i feel the color in my cheeks rising
again
i must be the color of the communist
manifesto stop talking stop talking now
i was in the area he says by way of
explanation i need to stock up on a few
things it's a pleasure to see you again
ms steele his voice is warm and husky
like dark melted chocolate fudge caramel
or something what's vanilla sex i ask if
anything to distract myself from the
intense burning sexy look he's giving me
he laughs
just straightforward sex anastasia no
toys no
add-ons
he shrugs you know well well
actually you don't but that's what it
means oh i thought it was chocolate
fudge brownie sex that we had with a
cherry on top but hey what do i know
mitchell also has an awkward habit of
juxtaposing erotic imagery with
infantilizing internal commentary from
anastasia anna is seemingly perpetually
confused by the world around her and
naive to the point of farce a thread
that persists all the way to the very
end of the trilogy lastly mitchell
doesn't have a deft touch when it comes
to managing the sexual danger again
because she is or at least publicly
performs being completely unaware and in
denial that her writing steers into
areas of dubious consent there are many
many moments where anna is legitimately
afraid of what christian might do to her
to quote romance author jenny trout on
the issue while there is something of a
thrill factor in having the heroine be a
little afraid of the super alpha hero
you have to walk a really delicate
balance you don't want the reader to
think that the heroine is actually super
afraid of the hero or that she has a
reason to find him literally dangerous
because that's when the fear stops being
sexy this is for many readers a source
of much of their frustration the book
doesn't manage to balance sexy danger
but it also refuses to embrace the
danger danger that it creates there's a
potentially legitimately decent erotic
thriller or even erotic horror somewhere
inside the subject matter but erika
mitchell seems convinced that living in
constant fear of your sexual partner's
temper is just what a kinky sex life
looks like
and
yeah i think that's enough context
to start talking about the movie
fifty shades of grey is a 2015 film
written by kelly marcel and directed by
sam taylor johnson based on the 2011
novel of the same name in this project
the two women were given the task of
wrangling a trashy bdsm erotica novel
full of clumsy plot abusive threadbare
characters and awful dialogue into a
sellable movie so i'm going to start
this off with the admission that i
actually kind of like the first fifty
shades movie
not because it's any good but because
there's a certain
creative verve to it like the filmmakers
were actually trying really hard to
capitalize creatively on this momentary
zeitgeist rather than simply cashing in
and riding the money train through three
basically guaranteed jobs there's a
dynamic around the first film that i
found compelling particularly how it was
cast in many circles as the worst film
of the year when really it was just
fairly middling as someone who has read
the source material i was largely
entertained by mentally cataloging all
the points where the film had managed to
improve on the source material coming
frustratingly close to making it
actually kind of good or at least trashy
fun if i took bits and pieces only
showed you the best clips i could
probably put together a convincing
argument that this is actually a really
good film
director sam taylor-johnson and
screenwriter kelly marcel both publicly
clashed with mitchell over the course of
the project and in both cases the
conflict revolved principally around
changes to the source material this is
ironic because the source material is
easily the worst thing about the movie
this is also the thing where
well
i mean the whole thing was ultimately
doomed in the deal with universal in
focus mitchell retained a massive amount
of creative control with something
nearly approaching total veto power over
any creative decision
and
well if her books are any indication
creativity isn't her strong suit still
the film diverges subtly but
substantially from the book the middle
of the story has been cleaned up and
more or less sorted out scenes have been
merged deleted had their locations
changed lots of small adaptational stuff
a huge change anna's inner monologue has
been dropped entirely while she is still
the point of view character with the
camera rarely cutting away the scenes
that she's not in she is no longer the
narrator this has substantial and
far-reaching impacts on both the general
tone and reading of the story but
particularly on anna's character
double crap
me and my two left feet
miss kevin
holy cow he's so young
you all right
if this guy's over 30 then i'm a
monkey's uncle christian
holy crap
what the hell is he doing here looking
all outdoorsy with his tousled hair and
in his cream chunky knit sweater jeans
and walking boots
i thought it was you
what the
what a pleasant surprise miss deal
just anna
i'm not gonna touch you
not until i have your written consent
what does that mean does he white slave
small children to some god-forsaken part
of the planet is he part of some
underworld crime syndicate it would
explain why he's so rich is he deeply
religious is he impotent surely not he
could prove that to me right now what
anna is generally made more competent
and proactive simply by excluding all
the times in the book where something
will happen and her inner monologue will
comment on how she doesn't understand
what's going on or what people are
talking about movie anna is a lot more
confident funnier emotionally aware and
less of a swooning catastrophe and the
movie cuts out the dozen or so times
that small interactions with christian
leave her a sobbing wreck she also
doesn't complain endlessly in her head
about her friends and is quicker to put
her foot down when christian gets out of
line it is left to the audience to
extrapolate from dakota johnson's acting
exactly how comfortable and safe they
think anna is in any given scene as a
further consequence of moving the point
of view out of anna's head it
dramatically alters the abusive elements
of the book and this in turn ties into
changes to christian who as a character
has been softened to be a bit more
natural and less volatile he doesn't
scream at people he doesn't berate anna
constantly for her eating habits he
doesn't talk constantly about wanting to
possess her he's just a bad kind of
needy boyfriend that's still not good
but it means there's at least something
likable about movie christian where book
christian is cruel capricious and
constantly on the edge of violence i'll
just make a call i murmur i just want to
hear kate's voice he frowns the
photographer his jaw clenches and his
eyes burn i blanket him i don't like to
share miss steele
remember that his quiet chilling tone is
a warning and with one long cold look at
me he heads back to the bedroom holy
crap i just wanted to call kate i want
to call after him but his sudden
aloftness has left me paralyzed what
happened to the generous relaxed smiling
man who was making love to me not half
an hour ago and this is a good point to
mention that it's kind of okay if
christian is a garbage person like from
a narrative standpoint it's not bad that
christian is bad that he's a bad person
or a bad boyfriend it's a story it's
drama we want conflict we want some
volatility and excitement and even a
level of emotional intensity that would
be exhausting in real life but is fun to
pretend with for a few hours him being a
bad boyfriend a poor communicator
emotionally distant these give the
characters things to conflict over
things for them to clash against
generating tension drama and story to
take an example from later in the film
christian spanx anna in a way that the
film plays as playful there's a lot of
good tension in the scene with anna's
conflicting desires and yeah dakota
johnson has played the scene as anna
realizing that she kinda likes it and
then christian up and leaves and anna
being abandoned starts to break down
from the intensity of it this is
actually really good drama it's
presented as not any one thing but the
aggregate combination of the intensity
and christian's emotional unavailability
it's left to the viewer to decide just
how far they think anna thinks christian
has gone what has been removed are the
pages of internal monologue where anna
feels like she's been assaulted but
rationalizes it away because of how much
she loves christian i stare down at my
hands what can i say that i haven't said
already i want more i want him to stay
because he wants to stay with me not
because i'm a blubbering mess and i
don't want him to beat me is that so
unreasonable
this is how book anna consistently
frames the encounter she doesn't process
it as play but as abuse and christian
dismisses her concerns out of hand so
you felt demeaned debased abused
assaulted how very test derby field of
you
i believe it was you who decided on the
debasement if i remember correctly
do you really feel like this or do you
think you ought to feel like this
two very
different things
if that is how you feel
do you think you could just try to
embrace these feelings deal with them
for me
that's what a submissive would do again
this isn't from a story perspective
strictly bad in isolation it is a source
of conflict but the real world
implications are troubling and the
conflict is never confronted or properly
resolved christian just tells anna to
get over it that if she really loved him
she'd be a good submissive and just deal
with it and that friction
never becomes part of book anna's
motivations moving on the entire opening
of the film is a great case study in the
difference in skill and craft between
the original and the filmmakers the
opening montage is actually really good
lots of good leading lines lots of well
juxtaposed shots and parallels it sets
the color palette the musical tone the
visual pace it's really solid filmmaking
fundamentals this shot of anna looking
up at gray house where it's all slanted
because it's putting her off kilter is
great judicious use of a dutch angle
that also helps fit a very tall building
into a narrow frame using visuals to
contrast anna and christian is a much
better introduction to the two
characters than they get in the book
where they don't even really have one
because they're clearly bella and edward
who you already know because you dear
fan fiction reader have read all of
twilight twice
first
i don't make love
i [ __ ]
hard a significant alteration to the
interview is injecting a bit of
awareness of the lameness of the
interview as written in the book where
anna asks a series of banal and low-key
insulting questions that christian just
answers one after the other there's a
bit of verbal sparring but it's
overwhelmingly the kind of utilitarian
information dump that serves to get the
fan fiction reader up to speed on the
new rules of the story's universe the
filmmakers wisely discard most of this
and plant two moments in to acknowledge
that the interview kinda sucks
uh you are very young to have amassed
such an empire to what do you what do i
owe my success
yep
but then unfortunately the source
material comes crashing back in
are you gay
all right okay okay let's pause for a
bit so
this is as good a time as any to mention
the shades of homophobia and misogyny
that lay over master of the universe and
all subsequent derivatives in the books
given that the reader is privy to all of
anna's thoughts it becomes obvious
almost comical how almost every man and
woman that anna comes across is
evaluated as a possible sexual
competitor particularly relevant to this
scene christian staffs his office
exclusively with hot blonde women in
tight skirts and blazers and anna starts
to refer to them throughout the books as
the stepford blondes anna's blonde
roommate kate also falls into a
relationship with a billionaire starting
a fling with christian's brother elliot
that also evolves over the course of the
books into marriage and babies but kate
is subject to endless internal criticism
for doing
well pretty much exactly what anna is
doing elliot grins and pulls kaiden to
his arms where she is more than happy to
be kate even in my inebriated state i am
shocked she only just met him then
there's the gay thing
are you gay there's a character a
masseuse dropped from the movies that
the books go to comical lengths to point
out that he's gay totally gay super gay
definitely gay and thus allowed to be
around anna when christian isn't there
then of course there's this which
somehow made it all the way through the
adaptation process including the even
stranger companion line from later where
anna spreads the rumor to undercut two
of her classmates that she overhears
talking about how cute her secret
boyfriend is
she is
i'm i'm actually at a complete loss as
to why that's there however bad as this
question may be it does lead into a
great example of how much better the
film is than the novel in the book anna
and christian are sitting on a large
couch for the entire interview they just
sit down and talk and talk and
eventually the time for the interview
runs out when one of the blondes comes
in and tells him his next meeting is
almost ready to start but christian
cancels it the lead-in to christian
canceling the meeting is anna telling
christian that kate is sick did you
volunteer to do this interview he asks
his voice deadly quiet hang on who's
supposed to be interviewing whom his
eyes burn into me and i'm compelled to
answer with the truth i was drafted
she's not well my voice is weak and
apologetic that explains
a great deal there's a knock at the door
and blonde number two enters mr gray
forgive me for interrupting but your
next meeting is in two minutes we're not
finished here andrea please cancel my
next meeting in contrast here's how the
movie handles the same transition point
in the conversation what about you
why did you ask me something that you
want to know
earlier you said that there are some
people who know you well
why do i get the feeling that that is
not true
mr gray your next meeting is in the
conference room council please we're not
finished here yes sir so first of all
we're working with visual levels
christian spends most of the scene
standing over anna a straightforward
power position but with the turning
point he moves to the chair brings
himself down to anna's level so we have
some visual power play second rather
than leading into christian cancelling
the meeting with a banal point about
kate being sick it's a pointed question
from anna that is actually disarming
this question paraphrased why do i get
the feeling no one knows the real you
piques his interest it creates an
honest-to-god emotional exchange
christian invites anna to test him even
disarms himself a little as part of his
game and she cuts right through his
facade i just wonder if
perhaps your heart might be a bit bigger
than you want to let on
but this question also makes anna into a
far more emotionally intelligent
character than she is in the novels
movie anastasia sees right through most
of christian's games where the novel
version of this exchange is predatory
christian manipulating the largely
oblivious anna the film version has
christian attempting to toy with anna
and being caught off guard by her
response this is part of a pattern in
the film where anna has been injected
with a lot of much-needed narrative
agency
he asked me to go for coffee afterwards
this one line for example actually
represents a huge change to anna's
character versus the novels this scene
is from chapter 3 of the book and in the
book the whole process of negotiating
going for coffee takes a page and a half
of arguing the logistics of who is going
to drive jose and his assistant home
because anna doesn't actually want to go
or she's not sure if she wants to and
maybe she wants to but she kind of
doesn't i wondered if you would join me
for coffee this morning my heart slams
into my mouth
a date
christian gray is asking me on a date
you haven't woken up yet my subconscious
winds at me in a sneering mood again i
clear my throat taylor who had been
retreating down the corridor turns and
heads back toward us are they based at
the university mr gray taylor asks when
he reaches us giving nothing away please
can you drive the photographer his
assistant smiles as if it's a done deal
i frown um mr great er this really i'll
swap vehicles with kate if you give me
so i can go in
i scoot around she says with no preamble
just stop talking buy some miracles if
you take wanda can i take your car
why
christian gray has asked me to go for
coffee with him
he asked me to go for coffee afterwards
the filmmakers have put in effort to
create actual escalation this small
change having anna actually
want to go for coffee
at least kind of makes things look like
some hot and cold romantic tension the
thing with the books is that anna
constantly and i do mean
constantly mentally beats the crap out
of herself for the idea of liking
christian and having any sort of sexual
ideas she is perpetually on the verge of
a complete
meltdown like at the end of the coffee
scene which the filmmakers have
mercifully reworked into something
resembling human dialogue anna is almost
hit by a cyclist but is pulled out of
the way by christian and then they look
into each other's eyes and he tells her
she should stay away from him because
they're no good for each other in the
film that's it anna looks a bit sad
because i mean she's just been pretty
clearly rejected but she walks away and
goes about her life we skip to later in
an otherwise normal week in the book she
goes into the parking garage and has a
complete sobbing meltdown that leaves
her curled up in the fetal position on
the concrete what was i thinking
unbidden and unwelcome tears pool in my
eyes
why am i crying i sink to the ground
angry at myself for this senseless
reaction drying up my knees i fold in on
myself i want to make myself as small as
possible adding this stability to the
character leads to some of the film's
best moments and some legitimately fun
and funny lines like anna and her
friends go out drinking to celebrate the
end of their exams and while standing in
line for the washroom anna drunk dials
christian while on the phone she quite
accurately mocks christian's behavior up
to that point listen to me i want you to
go home right now you're so bossy anna
let's go for coffee anna
let's go for coffee no
stay away from me anna i don't want you
to get away come here come here go away
that's it tell me where you are it's
great that's hilarious
this of course works because movie anna
is actually able to more or less
accurately read his emotional state
where book anna is confused by
everything now up to this point we're
about 22 minutes into the movie the
filmmakers have done an admirable job of
massaging the story into something with
actual pacing and maybe a little less
nonsense within the constraint of not
being allowed to alter any plot points
unfortunately
this scene is when they run up against
that as an inescapable problem
it's the big jump in the plot that
needed the most work to smooth it over
and they weren't allowed to touch it so
going off the broad template for these
types of stories we have our hot and
cold intro where the two characters
circle each other for a bit then the
first big break where they fall apart
and then something that brings them
crashing back into each other gwen hayes
in her book romancing the beat how to
write kissing books calls this moment
adhesion because it doesn't just bring
the characters back together but is the
point that they get stuck that last
point can be really hard to come up with
in a satisfying way especially when the
characters are as is the case here from
two radically different worlds that
don't really intersect how do you get
the billionaire and the university
student back together how do you get
them to stay together it's challenging
so being in a situation where they were
forbidden from changing the plot point
the filmmakers had a choice
do we keep the detail about christian
hacking her phone or not how did you
find me attract your cell phone
anastasia oh of course he did how is
that possible is it legal
stalker my subconscious whispers at me
through the cloud of tequila that's
still floating in my brain but somehow
because it's him i don't mind
yeah maybe a good skip there
the scene still has problems like elliot
just sort of being invented out of
nowhere christian and elliot being
inside the bar already stuff like that a
lot changes very quickly this is
somewhat mitigated in the movie because
the cut from standing in line for the
washroom to leaving the bar is a bit
more ambiguous where the book follows
anna through every step in between and
i'm pretty sure christian and elliot get
to the bar faster than they should have
been able to get to the hotel's parking
garage and since we're at the bar okay
we should talk about jose so the problem
with jose is a problem that goes back to
the very beginning and i'm not talking
about the low-key racism the dios mios
or the fact that jose tries to molest
anna though you know
make note of all of those no what we're
talking about is the narrative utility
of jose and how he fits or more often
fails to fit into the story here's what
jose does in the books he's anna and
kate's friend though he's an engineering
major and not an english major he does
photography though mostly architecture
but gets press ganged into doing
christian's head shots for kate's
article because her normal photographer
isn't available after exams are done he
goes out drinking with kate and anna
tries to get anna super drunk then
gropes her in the parking lot before
christian intervenes
marcel and taylor johnson had the right
idea that at this point jose's narrative
utility if not his friendship with anna
is done and he more or less disappears
for the rest of the movie in the book he
continues to float around in the
background and anna's like oh what's a
little attempted date rape between
friends just don't do it again and he's
always sort of there as though he's
going to form part of a love triangle
that never happens because he's jacob
black and you can't just cut him out of
your fan fiction or team jacob will
revolt it's a little weird
it's just beyond this door
what is
my playroom
like your xbox and stuff
the dialogue in the playroom is lifted
straight out of the book so of course
it's all
awful
i'm a dominant
what does that mean
it means i want you to willingly
surrender yourself to me
why would i do that
please man
all the scenes in the playroom are the
scenes that according to sam taylor
johnson mitchell was most protective of
christian does an awful job at pitching
the whole situation which
kind of makes sense given what his
actual damage is but the problem
is that we're not going to learn that
he's actually really bad at the whole
dom thing until really far into the next
movie
like okay it isn't actually acknowledged
until
842 pages into the series
i'm a sadist i like to whip little brown
haired girls like you because you all
look like the crack [ __ ]
my birth mother
even then that subject is going to be
more or less compartmentalized to a
single scene it's an element that's
never confronted so much as sidestepped
by having the characters never actually
engage in any meaningful sd interactions
beyond anna's lightweight brat routine
the outcome of which is mostly light
bondage and a bit of spanking
it's also undercut by the whole thing
where christian insists that he doesn't
do dates has never slept in the same bed
as someone else doesn't do romance and
flowers and love making but
he does
he took her out for coffee
that's a date at least they follow up
this first playroom scene with another
substantial change for the better when
anna tells christian that she's still a
virgin
because i have i haven't
you're still a virgin now
this plot point is retained from the
book and it still feels kind of
fetishistic and is a bit off-putting for
that but how it's responded to is
substantially better in the book
christian stalks around the room running
his hands through his hair yelling and
growling and castigating anna you're a
virgin
i nod flushing again he closes his eyes
and looks to be counting to ten when he
opens them again he's angry glaring at
me why the [ __ ] didn't you tell me
christian is running his hands through
his hair and pacing up and down his
study
two hands that's double exasperation
his usual concrete control seems to have
slipped a notch
i don't understand why you didn't tell
me he castigates me the subject never
came up i'm not in the habit of
revealing my sexual status to everyone i
meet i mean we hardly know each other
i'm staring at my hands why am i feeling
guilty why is he so mad i peek up at him
well you know a lot more about me now he
snaps his mouth presses into a hard line
i knew you were inexperienced but
a virgin he says it like it's a really
dirty word
marcel and taylor johnson on the other
hand lay on the mushy romance
where have you been
waiting
men must throw themselves at you
never what i've wanted
this does however just further detail
that basic flaw in the telling of
christian's character christian has
spent multiple scenes telling anna all
about how he doesn't do romance doesn't
do flowers doesn't do dates first
i don't make love
i [ __ ]
hard but
at a pin drop he just decides some old
fashioned lovemaking is in order
so
yeah i try not to get in the habit of
suggesting fixes but it's really hard
not to do that here just have anna be
the one to escalate once they start
kissing i mean that's the whole conflict
here isn't it anna's moony-eyed romance
versus christian's business-like
dominance maybe have a bit more push and
pull with that he gets her to try out
some spanky stuff and she finds out she
likes it he opens up a bit to flowers
and romance and finds out it's not so
bad either that kinda is the big
emotional arc here and it is eventually
acknowledged when christian agrees to a
regular date night once a week that for
the record never happens but maybe
introduce that idea a bit earlier than i
don't know
260 pages into the book but that's
really an unfair comparison because
again in the book version of this scene
christian is stalking the room and
yelling at anna and talks at length
about how he's just having sex with her
to rectify her virginity which he sees
as a problem
so
yeah
i've never taken anyone
in the helicopter
i've never
had sex
in my own bed
i've never slept next to anyone
when they're walking out in the woods on
the way back to portland this happens
again where christian tells anna and us
all the things that he's done with anna
that he's never done with anyone else
like taking them in the helicopter
having sex in his sleeping bed instead
of his designated sex bed having sex
that was outside the frame of a
submission and domination relationship
but the impact of that is undercut by
the fact that there hasn't really been
any conflict there there's no friction
for christian he's not unsure of himself
he's not lost he enjoys it well enough
so it's not a character growth moment
really he's just describing the fact
that yesterday he experienced an
incredibly banal first anna before
yesterday i'd i'd never had boo berry
before we always got corn pops and when
you put rooster sauce on the eggs i'd
never done that before either
they were okay so what this scene ends
up doing which i think almost works if
you put this first film in a bottle is
it emphasizes that christian's reticence
to compromise is pretty unreasonable it
still doesn't do that well but it does
do it this is an important contrast to
anna who has stepped far more
dramatically outside her comfort zone
and found that she is for the most part
overwhelmed by the scope and intensity
of what christian is asking far more
than any small part and again it needs
to be highlighted that christian really
isn't presented as breaking through any
significant hurdles there is no conflict
leading up to christian asking anna out
for coffee there's no panic attack about
wanting to take a romantic interest
flying in his helicopter it's effortless
there's a lot of nuanced argument over
the idea of show don't tell like we can
come up with all kinds of examples where
just telling the audience what's going
on is actually pretty effective and then
we could get into further debate over
whether or not those examples are still
supported or themselves support visual
or environmental evidence that shows the
thing we are being told and thus it's
all a combination of showing and telling
but this
right here
christian grey just saying it's a big
deal that he's never had sex in his
sleeping bed instead of his sex bed
this right here is the poster child for
the kind of limp storytelling that leads
to getting your writing back from the
editor with show don't tell written in
big red letters in the margin we are
told that this is a conflict that this
is all outside christian's comfort zone
but that conflict is supported by
absolutely nothing else as a result this
point ends up falling into a hazy space
where it's not a satisfying parallel
between the two characters because the
stakes are so disproportionate but it's
also not just cute banter because
there's clearly supposed to be weight to
it in the cinematic language this is the
culmination of a scene where christian
tells anna the first inkling of his dark
past and admits that he's still friends
with the woman who raped him when he was
a teenager the characters are framed at
a path's dead end on the edge of dark
water anna is trapped visually in the
noisy chaotic half of the frame with
christian acting as the barrier between
a cage and freedom the soundtrack is
tense kind of sinister visually the
color palette of the scene gets colder
as the scene progresses when they walk
down the path the highlights are warm at
the docks they're neutral and when we
come in for the close-up they're cool
and muted the scene is emotionally and
literally getting darker
but for what this is the kind of moment
that encapsulates why this movie stuck
with me in the way it did moments of
talented subtle filmmaking in the
service of material that just doesn't
know justice the biggest example of this
is the negotiation earlier we discussed
how the middle of the book is a mess
lots of disjointed chapters repeated
scenes fragmented developments and awful
stuff this is where they managed to sort
most of that out the scene is an
amalgamation of mostly chapters 13 and
15. two of the worst in the book i say
worst because there are a couple of the
scenes where we get the clearest example
of christian just absolutely
disregarding anna's agency comfort and
explicit wishes
in the first a dinner meeting anna
explicitly asks that they stay in public
for the conversation and christian
immediately moves her to a private
dining room i think we should stay in
public on neutral ground he smiles
sardonically do you think that would
stop me he says softly a sensual warning
my eyes widen and i swallow again i hope
so come i have a private dining room
booked
no public in the second the actual meat
and potatoes negotiation
christian keeps pressing anna to drink
more despite anna being a lightweight
let's not go too far we know your
capacity for alcohol is limited
anastasia he picks up the champagne
takes off the foil top and cage twist
the bottle rather than he fills my cup
is he getting me tipsy i eye him
suspiciously he glances quickly at me
more
than i drink practically all of it
again more he asks work more
my brain is beginning to fog
hmm
oh did you give me tipsy on purpose yes
why because you overthink
everything and you're reticent like your
stepdad a drop of wine in you and you
start talking and i need you to
communicate honestly with me otherwise
you clam up and i have no idea what
you're thinking
in vino veritas anastasia nothing freaks
me out more than people who say this is
about domestic abuse
yeah
anyway the filmmakers have pulled all of
the negotiation stuff together into a
single scene that really gives us an
idea of what things maybe could have
looked like in an alternate universe
where mitchell had less control over the
project it's witty it's sassy it's fun
there's a cute power play between the
characters this is part of the overall
trend of imbuing movie anna with more
agency and awareness she isn't getting
under his skin by accident she's
deliberately flirting
find anal fisting
i'm all ears
strike it out
strike out vaginal fisting too
you sure
yep
it also ties into the changes to
christian anna isn't afraid of what he's
going to do how he's going to respond
she's not worried that she's making him
angry it creates a much needed dramatic
moment where it looks like things might
actually work out that they'll be able
to reach a proper compromise before
everything starts to fall apart again
this is the midpoint the false high and
for the most part this scene works in
its own little bubble i mean out of the
bubble it's a complete waste because
despite the fact that they have this
whole negotiation where anna gets
basically all the concessions that she
wants and then in the next scene at her
graduation she tells christian yes she
still doesn't physically sign the
contract and it becomes something that
they argue about on and off for the rest
of the book movie because both do a
really poor job at distinguishing
between kinky sex which is what they
still do and the full on 24 7 total
package dom sub lifestyle that christian
wants
and this is where the movie actually
stumbles counter-intuitively getting
less coherent by being better like okay
it still doesn't make sense in the book
what the actual stakes are because the
two of them are just endlessly arguing
about nothing but that kind of gets
worse in the movie because the movie
versions of the characters are at least
nominally capable of having an honest
and open conversation about their
relationship so changing it to be a
scene where anna is sober and
professional and gets christian to make
numerous compromises but never addresses
the punishment angle actually makes less
sense than a scene where christian gets
anna drunk and steamrolls her opinions
with a few minor concessions but still
the lighting works the timing works the
acting works danny elfman's score is at
its most
danny elfman
eroticism is used to build the
characters and tell the story which is
not what can be said for about 90 of the
sex in both the book and the movie i
think the scenes in 50 shades are well
shot they're well lit they're well
scored and they manage to convey an
engaging level of eroticism so they're
at least trashy fun but there's a deeper
problem where they fail to work as
scenes
almost all of them can be cut from the
film and leave little impact with their
absence this actually makes a lot of
sense if we go all the way back and
review the origins of the text master of
the universe as you'll recall was
originally published on fanfiction.net
which has a prohibition on sexually
explicit content
how effective that prohibition has
historically been is up for debate but
regardless erica mitchell worked around
it by posting saucy versions of the
story there and more explicit versions
to her personal website so if it seems
like the characters do all their
relevant character talking and then stop
to have sex that the sex scenes are a
post-hoc addition to the actual story
it's because they are this is all just a
roundabout way of getting around to
talking about the end of the film so
when the film was in production the
second and third films had not
technically been greenlit yet there were
contracts securing principal creatives
in the event of the second and third
films being made but fifty shades of
grey went into production with the
possibility that it would be the only
adaptation actually made i know it seems
silly to think that paramount would only
make one of the books into a movie in a
post-harry potter hunger games world but
also consider that while 50 shades rise
to fame had been swift there was always
the possibility that it would fade just
as quickly if you buy the film rights in
2013 for a book that had only really
been out for a year and a half how sure
are you that audiences will still be
around in four five years by the time
darker and freed were greenlit gray was
already deep into post-production i
bring it up because it places unique
creative pressure on the director and
screenwriter who now need to try and
craft a movie that will work both as a
potential stand-alone film and as the
first act of a three-part series with
that as for play let's talk about the
final scene in the playroom the belt
whipping scene
alright so something vague has gone
wrong with christian's vague business
stuff in the book i think it's that one
of christian's cargo boats with relief
aid food bound for africa is sunk by
pirates
or something
and he's sunk into a deep funk over this
anna tries to sex him back to happiness
by letting him tie her up and blindfold
her but it doesn't work because it's not
extreme enough so he's sitting up late
at night playing sad piano the two of
them have a very confusing argument
about the contract that anna has agreed
to but not signed that ultimately kind
of revolves around the fact that anna
really just doesn't like the idea of
punishment this is actually where a lot
of kink and bdsm enthusiasts take the
most umbrage because the specific
dominant submissive interaction of rules
and punishments and rewards is where
erica mitchell basically says that if
people enjoy those kinds of games it's
because they're emotionally damaged why
it's the way i am either way the
conversation gets more confusing when
christian insists that the contract is
still in force in spirit even though she
didn't sign it and if she acts out there
will be punishment and so anna says okay
fine show me how bad it can get and
christian brings her into the play room
and tells her he's going to whip her
with a belt six times now i want to
reiterate something i said earlier from
a story standpoint
it's okay if christian is a bit of a
bastard because it gives the characters
something to conflict over
just something needs to come of it one
of the things that sam taylor johnson
wanted to do with this scene was have
anna use her safe word red
while christian keeps going and that
is actually a brilliant change or it
would have been if it had happened it
properly centers the conflict around
christian's actual character flaws it
calls attention to his selfishness makes
his disregard for anastasia's well-being
explicit and gives anna a very
very good reason to leave the
relationship immediately
it is an overt betrayal of her trust it
says that christian thinks he's in
control but ultimately lacks the
self-control to restrain himself it
points out that his love of rules is
ultimately a shallow facade to justify
his very mundane abuse
that right there shows us the thing that
mitchell is going to try to tell us in
the next book i like to whip little
brown-haired girls like you it would
have been a great change
and erica mitchell
lost her mind reports from set are that
this dialogue change triggered an
hour-long shouting match in front of
cast and crew until ultimately mitchell
got her way the scene as included in the
movie plays out pretty much exactly the
same as it does in the book where anna
takes the whipping and then freaks out
because she can't
quite process that christian likes the s
and m parts of bdsm anyway sam taylor
johnson and kelly marcel are far better
storytellers than erica mitchell and
they understand mitchell's story better
than she does as evidenced by the
closing moments of the film where anna
goes to leave christian moves to
intercept her and she tells him no
stop
no
of course that would play a million
times better if the story had actually
been about boundaries but
as it is it still plays as part of an
artistically strong final scene
culminating in the fantastic final shot
of the theatrical edition
well
christian
the unrated edition adds a sad montage
that is weaker as a standalone film but
ties into fifty shades darker a bit more
naturally again that challenge of making
a film that will work as both it's kind
of the bottom line here the film is
surprisingly well made with a deliberate
artfulness for a movie that still
ultimately isn't very good it's
watchable and it has its distinct
highlights and craft and skill there are
scenes and moments that are good even
great but the whole is still less than
the sum of its parts undercut by
fundamentally flawed source material and
with all that
conclusion of video bloody block closing
statements
we're going to keep going with this
that's right we're not done we've got
two more of these suckers to get through
and it's all downhill from here oh yeah
just you wait some stuff to look forward
to when we talk about darker sam taylor
johnson and kelly marcel getting fired
for you know trying to make the movie
better the serial thickness ramping up
to high gear the budget cuts the
helicopter crash the stalkers
why do you have my bank account details
online hits don't automatically
translate to print sales well
but they could the right term is a
sadist
i get often punishing women women who
look like you like your mother
field and our reporter rachel taylor
rachel
thank you john i'm speaking to you live
from the private helicopter terminal at
seattle
gray and his colleague roz bailey have
been found safe and well and are at this
moment on their way back to seattle
sources tell us
what the hell are y'all doing here oh
boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you